يعيش أكثر من مليوني فلسطيني
في غزة، نصفهم تقريبًا من الأطفال،
فلنحضر حنين أوكال، وهي
فلسطينية أمريكية من مقاطعة يونيون في
نيوجيرسي، وهي عالقة حاليًا في
مدينة غزة مع أطفالها الثلاثة الذين يبلغون من
العمر 8 أعوام وسنتين وشهرين.
لا يمكنهم الخروج، شكرًا جزيلاً لك،
على انضمامك إلينا، هل تمكنت سفارة الولايات المتحدة من إيصالك،
وإعطائك أي مساعدة للخروج،
مرحبًا، كيف حالك، نعم، لقد حاولنا السفر إلى
الولايات المتحدة مرات عديدة، لسوء الحظ
لم يتمكنوا من المساعدة  لقد اتصلت
بهم على الإطلاق عبر الهاتف VI عبر البريد الإلكتروني الذي أرسلته عبر البريد الإلكتروني
واتصلت بأرقام مختلفة ولكن
لم أتمكن من تلقي رد من
أي شخص. قالوا إننا نتصل بك من GNA مرة
أخرى في غضون 24 ساعة أو نحو ذلك بضع
ساعات لكنهم  لم يتمكنوا من
الاتصال بنا على الإطلاق أو لم نحصل على أي
معلومات منهم لقد تقدمت بطلب وقمت
بتقديم نموذج أه من خلال الموقع
ولكن ذلك لم ينجح أيضًا
ولا أعرف ما الذي حدث  مع معبر
أراس الحدودي وما الذي يحدث
مع حدود سلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني، لا أعرف ما إذا
كنا سننجح ولكنني
أتطلع تمامًا إلى مساعدة
السفارة الأمريكية، فنحن جميعًا هنا نشعر بأننا
مهجورون ونشعر بذلك  لقد
تركنا بمفردنا، لذلك نحن نبحث حقًا
عن السفارة الأمريكية أه لمساعدة
المواطنين الأمريكيين الذين يعيشون في غزة، وكانت
مجرد غارة جوية إسرائيلية
سمعنا للتو أنها كانت مجرد غارة جوية إسرائيلية
سمعنا للتو ما الذي  أننا سمعنا للتو
صوتًا مثل قنبلة أو صاروخ هو
ما سمعناه للتو في نعم نعم نعم
يحدث ذلك على مدار 24 ساعة أم طوال الوقت إنهم
يرتطمون في كل
مكان أه من الجنوب إلى الشمال أه إلى
وسط غزة في كل مكان الضخ في
كل مكان  كيف
حال أطفالك مع هذا الأمر
الفظيع، أطفالي
خائفون جدًا ويخافون مما يحدث،
يجب أن أشرح لهم طوال
الوقت، يجب أن أهدئهم وأحاول أن
أجعلهم يشعرون بالراحة
والأمان  وأه
أحاول أن أشغلهم
بأشياء أخرى أه حتى لا يشعروا بالخوف أو
الخوف ولكن مثل ما
حدث معي على سبيل المثال اليوم كنت
سأحاول الخروج من غزة كنت
ذاهب أه إلى حدود سلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني وأه  بينما
نحن ذاهبون إلى هناك حاولنا عدة طرق
للخروج من أه أه غزة متجهين إلى سلاح الجو الملكي البريطاني إلى
الجنوب أه لم نتمكن من الوصول على الإطلاق
لذلك رأى ابني جميع المواقع
تدمر أماكنه المفضلة التي
صدم بها  ما رآه لذلك كان علينا أن
نرى كل ذلك وكان علينا أن نمر
عبر ما
نقوله حسنًا، لذلك كان الأمر كما لو كنت تعلم أنك
ستموت
نعم، يجب أن تكون هناك طريقة
للخروج، أعني أنك'  أنت لست حماس،
أنت شخص بريء ولديك
ثلاثة أطفال تحتاج إلى أن تتمكن من
الخروج، لقد سمعت في وقت سابق
اقتراحات المتحدث باسم الجيش الإسرائيلي الذي
تحدثت معه ليلة السبت، أين من
المفترض أن يذهب الفلسطينيون الأبرياء،
قال إنه يمكنك الذهاب إلى  الجنوب يمكنك الذهاب
إلى الشاطئ هو أمر واقعي على الإطلاق، لقد
سمعنا للتو عن محاولتك
الذهاب إلى المعبر الحدودي في الجنوب وهذا
لم ينجح، هل هناك
أي مكان يمكنك الذهاب إليه للهروب أه
للهروب من هذا  وابل من
الصواريخ لا، لقد حاولنا في كل مكان يقولون
اذهب إلى الشاطئ ثم يصطدمون
بالشاطئ في اليوم التالي يقولون اذهب إلى
الشمال ثم يصطدمون بالمناطق الشمالية
أه في اليوم التالي يحبون كل مكان
يصطدمون في كل مكان لذا لا يوجد مكان  آمن
هنا في قطاع غزة،
ويبدو الأمر كما لو كان الأمر فظيعًا جدًا ومن
الصعب جدًا شرحه
لأنهم يصطدمون في كل مكان جيدًا
وآمل ألا يكون هذا مجرد مكان أو
مكان قريب من حماس، فهم
يصطدمون بالأماكن التي  لا علاقة لهم
بحماس مثل
اه لا أعرف في
كل مكان لدينا رقمك أعرف
أن البيت الأبيض يشاهد هذا العرض
يمكن للبيت الأبيض الاتصال بي وسنجعلهم
على اتصال معك أنت
وأطفالك بحاجة للخروج  آمن وتحتاج
إلى الخروج بأمان في أقرب وقت
ممكن من الناحية الإنسانية، يرجى البقاء آمنًا والبقاء على اتصال
معنا، وسنبذل كل ما في
وسعنا لمساعدتك،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك، وأنا أقدر ذلك،
شكرًا لك
على